This is the brief on the 2026 US
Iran strikes and the illusion of
nation building.
So right after those February
28th, 2026 US and Israeli
strikes killed Iran's supreme
leader Ali Khamenei and totally
ignited the region, a writer is
revisiting their 21 year old
warning about America's
dangerous.
Habit of endless foreign
intervention.
First, think of foreign
intervention kind of like a
boiling pot of water on a stove.
You know order is only
maintained as long as an outside
power supplies the heat with
troops and money.
The second you turn off that
heat, society snaps right back
to its natural state.
Just look at Afghanistan.
They simply waited out the
empires and that old Mujahideen
structure just re emerged as the
Taliban.
Second, let's break down the
whole myth of installing
democracy.
Removing dictators like Saddam
Hussein in Iraq or Muammar
Gaddafi in Libya didn't
magically create liberal
democracies.
Instead, it exposed some
incredibly fragile national
cohesion and created massive
power vacuums that militias were
just thrilled to fill.
Political systems grow from
history and culture, right?
You literally can't just install
them from the outside like a
quick software update.
Finally, we really got to beware
the trap of the permanent
crusade.
The author confesses they
actually voted for Donald Trump
three times specifically for his
anti interventionist.
No new wars promise.
And yet, well, we're back in
conflict anyway.
It proves John Quincy Adams 1821
morning perfectly.
If a nation goes abroad looking
for monsters to destroy, that
supply of monsters is literally
never going to run out.
So it leaves us asking, are we
actually exporting freedom or
simply putting another pot on
the stove and. 2026 And
depending on exactly when you
are listening to this deep dive,
you are, you're likely already
feeling the shock waves of what
happened just days ago.
Yeah, it's it's been a truly
staggering week.
Staggering is the word.
On February 28th, the United
States and Israel launched a
massive, highly coordinated
military strike campaign against
Iran.
And we're not talking about a
limited skirmish here.
This is a major opening wave of
attacks.
They specifically targeted
military facilities, command
centers and leadership compounds
all across the country.
He's in a massive escalation.
Exactly.
And the fallout was immediate.
It was catastrophic for the
Iranian hierarchy.
In that very first barrage of
strikes, Iran's supreme leader
Ali Khamenei was killed along
with a significant number of
senior figures in their military
leadership.
And the reaction, as you know,
as anyone paying attention might
expect, was instantaneous.
I mean, within hours of those
strikes, the entire region
essentially ignited.
Iran immediately retaliated.
They launched these massive
salvos of missiles and swarms of
drones aimed directly at US
bases and Israeli targets.
It's just it's terrifying to
watch unfold.
It really is.
And the global ripple effects,
well, they've been exactly what
you would anticipate from a
geopolitical earthquake of this
magnitude.
Oil markets are just convulsing
violently right now.
Which impacts everyone listening
to this.
Exactly.
And shipping routes through the
Persian Gulf, they suddenly look
incredibly uncertain.
That is directly threatening
global supply chains.
Governments all across the world
are frantically scrambling
behind closed doors.
They're trying to understand
what the next phase of this
escalation might actually look
like, and honestly, whether a
broader regional war is now
entirely unavoidable.
It really feels like a moment of
intense, almost suffocating
global anxiety.
It does.
And the justifications that we
are hearing right now, the ones
being offered by Washington and
Jerusalem for the 2026 strikes,
they sound incredibly familiar
to anyone who's been paying
attention over the last few
decades.
Oh, almost word for word.
Right.
We're hearing about the absolute
necessity of stopping Iran's
nuclear ambitions.
We're hearing about the urgent
need to halt their ballistic
missile programs, the imperative
to disrupt their regional proxy
networks, and the overarching
foundational argument that
removing a dangerous regime is
simply the only way to create
the conditions for a safer, more
stable Middle East.
And that that specific framing
brings us right to the actual
material we are unpacking today.
It does.
Today we are looking at a newly
published, incredibly timely
retrospective essay.
It's titled America Goes Abroad
in Search of Monsters to
Destroy, a 21 year postscript to
something I wrote in 2005.
It is a genuinely remarkable
piece of writing, mostly because
of the perspective the author
brings to this exact moment
we're living.
In Yeah, their reaction was
fascinating.
It really was because when they
saw the news of these massive
strikes on February 28th, their
reaction wasn't shocked, it
wasn't surprise.
They describe the feeling as
something much closer to a weary
recognition.
They watch this exact pattern,
these exact arguments playing
out 21 years ago.
So the mission of our discussion
today is to really understand
the cyclical nature of foreign
intervention through the eyes of
someone who predicted this very
dynamic over 2 decades ago.
We are going to unpack their
framework to ask a very
difficult, very provocative
question.
Does destroying monsters
actually make the world safer or
does it just lock us into a
permanent never ending crusade?
OK, let's unpack this, because
to truly grasp the author's
reaction to the events unfolding
around us right now in 2026, we
actually have to travel back in
time.
We have to go back 21 years,
specifically to February 14,
2005.
Right, but before we take that
jump back to 2005, it's probably
worth setting a quick baseline
for how we are going to navigate
this material today.
Good idea, because the author
goes after some serious sacred
cows here.
They critique both the political
left and the political right,
and they even get into their own
recent voting record.
So to be absolutely clear for
you listening, we are just here
to impartially unpack the
author's thesis today.
We are not here to endorse their
political views or take a side
in the partisan crossfire.
Absolutely not.
Their critique of the political
establishment is fascinating as
a lens for understanding foreign
policy.
So our job is simply to map out
that intellectual framework so
you can see the ideological
forces driving the chaos we are
watching on the news right now.
Exactly.
We are looking at the
architecture of the argument
here.
So picture the intellectual
climate of February 2005.
The United States was standing
the long, dark shadow of 911,
and the country was deeply,
messily entrenched in the
invasion of Iraq.
It was a very tense time.
Very.
And the entire country was
locked in this massive high
stakes philosophical argument.
The core debate wasn't just
about military tactics.
It was fun to Missy about
whether democracy could or even
should be exported abroad by
force.
That is the crucial context for
this whole essay, and the text
sets up this 2005 debate by
highlighting 2 incredibly
distinct opposing intellectual
heavyweights that were
completely dominating the
conversation at that time.
Right on one side, you had Natan
Sharansky.
Yes, on one side this highly
influential viewpoint
represented by Sharansky, his
writing had essentially become
required reading inside the Bush
administration back.
Then, which tells you how
seriously his ideas were taken.
Oh, absolutely.
The core of Sharansky's argument
was a theory of authoritarian
instability.
He argued that authoritarian
regimes are, by their very
nature, inherently unstable and
dangerous.
Why?
Because they rely on oppressing
their own people, right?
Therefore, according to this
worldview, spreading democratic
institutions around the world
isn't just a nice moral
sentiment, it is a hard
strategic necessity.
It's self-defense.
Exactly.
It's the belief that democracy
is the ultimate required
antidote to global instability,
and that free nations are
fundamentally safer nations.
So if you follow Sharansky's
logic, taking out a dictator
isn't just removing a bad guy,
it is actually defensive act
that creates long term safety
for everyone.
That was the promise.
But then, on the exact opposite
side of that philosophical
debate, you had Pat Buchanan,
and Buchanan was arguing
something radically different.
He was warning that this very
active interventionism, the
attempt to forcibly export
democratic systems, often
created the exact instability it
claimed it was trying to solve.
It is a total, irreconcilable
clash of worldviews, Sherensky
says.
The disease is authoritarianism
and the cure is imposed
democracy.
Yeah, Buchanan says.
Buchanan says the intervention
itself is the pathogen that
causes the fever.
If you smash the existing order,
even a bad order, you aren't
guaranteed to get a liberal
democracy.
You are much more likely to just
get chaos.
And hovering above this intense,
hyperpolarized 2005 debate, the
author brings in a voice from
even further back in American
history, a warning from John
Quincy Adams dating all the way
back to 1821.
Yes, the title of the peace.
Exactly, and I want to read this
carefully because as you know,
it's the absolute anchor for the
entire argument we are
dissecting today.
In 1821, Adams warned that
America quote does not go abroad
in search of monsters to destroy
it's.
Such a powerful line.
It really is, yeah.
He argued that the United States
could wish freedom and
independence for all nations and
could encourage it by example,
but that America should be the
vindicator only of its own
freedom.
What's fascinating here is how
the author reflects on the
evolution of that specific
quote.
They note that back in 2005,
when they wrote their original
blog post quoting John Quincy
Adams, that line still sounded
like a principle.
It sounded like an active,
guiding ethos that policy makers
were at least pretending to
debate.
But looking at it now, in 2026,
following these massive
coordinated strikes against Iran
and the deeply familiar
justifications used to launch
them, that 1821 warning reads
more like a line we simply
stopped believing entirely.
It really does.
Because when you look at the
actual actions taken over the
last two decades, the United
States unequivocally does go
abroad in search of monsters to
destroy.
Think about that for a second.
I want you, the listener, to
just reflect on your own
lifetime, however long you've
been following the news.
How many times have you heard
the exact same justifications
for military action recycled
almost word for word, decade
after decade?
It's.
A constant loop.
We must stop the weapons
programs, we must disrupt the
the proxy networks, we must
remove this specific dangerous
regime so we can finally create
a safer region.
Always the same script.
Always.
The author is pointing out that
what Adams explicitly warned
against two centuries ago hasn't
just been forgotten.
It has essentially become the
standard operating procedure for
foreign policy.
And the author is intellectually
honest enough to concede a point
here, which is important, very
important.
They acknowledge that perhaps in
this specific 2026 scenario with
Iran, the arguments for the
strikes will actually prove
correct.
Right.
History is complicated.
It is, and it occasionally
produces situations where
military force truly is the
least bad option on the table.
But it isn't the specific
tactical validity of the strikes
that alarms the author.
It is.
It's the overwhelming
familiarity of the rhetoric.
It's that creeping realization
that we are running the exact
same script we ran in 2005,
expecting a different ending.
Here's where it gets really
interesting Because to
understand why these
interventions keep happening,
and why they so consistently
failed to produce the lasting
democratic stability that
interventionists like Sharansky
promised, we have to look at how
policy makers misunderstand the
very nature of political order.
This part of the essay is
brilliant.
It really is, and the author
uses a highly clarifying
metaphor to explain this.
To understand the mechanics of
artificial political order, we
need to talk about a pot of
water on an aluminum stove.
I love when incredibly dense
geopolitical concepts are
distilled down into something
you can just visualize in your
kitchen.
Me too.
The author says this image of
the stove keeps returning to
their mind every single time
they watch another massive
nation building project unfold.
So visualize this.
You have a pot of water sitting
on a stove.
You turn on the flame and
eventually the water begins to
boil.
Simple physics.
Exactly.
You turn the heat down and the
boiling slows.
You turn the flame off entirely
and the water quickly cools down
and stops boiling altogether.
Now let's map the elements of
this physical metaphor onto the
actual realities of foreign
policy.
In this analogy, the boiling
water represents external
political order.
It's the structured, seemingly
stable functioning system that
an occupying or intervening
force is trying to desperately
create in a foreign country, and
the flame underneath the pot
that represents the outside
power.
The flame is the intervening
nation or the coalition of
nations, and the essay gives us
a very specific, extensive list
of the ingredients that actually
make up that heat.
Because it's not just dropping
bombs.
No, not at all.
When we talk about geopolitical
heat, we aren't just talking
about airstrikes and troops on
the ground, though that those
are obvious factors.
The heat is a massive,
incredibly expensive combination
of resources.
It's troops, yes, but it's also
billions of dollars in funding.
It's weapons shipments.
It's thousands of military and
civilian advisors.
It's the leverage of economic
sanctions.
It's the quiet hum of
intelligence networks and the
constant heavy hand of
diplomatic pressure.
So as long as that massive
complex apparatus of heat is
actively applied to the bottom
of the pot, a certain kind of
order can actually be
maintained.
Yes, the water boils.
The society looks active,
dynamic and structured according
to the specific desires of the
foreign power that's controlling
the dial.
You can look at that society and
say, look, it's working.
The government is functioning,
the military is training, the
institutions are running.
What's fascinating here is if we
connect this to the bigger
picture, we are really talking
about the physics of artificial
order.
Artificial being the keyword.
Exactly.
The critical thing to understand
is that this order is entirely
100% dependent on an external
energy source.
Because the absolute moment that
heat is reduced, the moment the
troops start pulling back, the
moment the money stops flowing
quite as freely, the moment the
diplomatic pressure eases up to
focus on some other crisis, the
system immediately begins
reverting.
Because water doesn't stay
boiling on its own.
It doesn't.
It reverts to whatever
equilibrium the society itself
produces organically.
The artificial boiling stops and
the underlying historical
structure of that society
reasserts itself.
And this highlights what the
author identifies as a critical,
almost tragic flaw in the
mindset of the people who
designed these foreign policies.
It's a massive blind spot.
It is Policymakers repeatedly,
stubbornly assume that the
boiling is permanent.
They look at a nation that has
been occupied, funded and
micromanaged by outside forces
for 5-10, maybe 15 years.
They see the institutions
functioning under that immense
artificial heat, and they
somehow convince themselves that
the water has magically learned
how to boil on its own.
Which, as the author points out,
is a fundamental
misunderstanding of
thermodynamics, both literally
and politically.
The history of intervention
keeps showing over and over
again that the boiling is never
permanent.
It simply cannot be.
Yet despite this blindingly
obvious historical track record,
the exact same playbook is
continually used.
Which raises a really important
question.
Why do smart, highly educated
policy makers keep making this
exact same mistake?
It is a profound disconnect,
isn't it?
It really is.
I mean, is it just staggering
hubris?
Is it a total overestimation of
American power?
This belief that enough money
and enough smart people can re
engineer any society on earth
and.
You'd be a bit of that.
Or is it a profound, almost
willful misunderstanding of how
deeply rooted local cultures
actually are?
You apply infinite money and
military power, you create a
facade of water, and you mistake
your own applied pressure for
organic societal transformation.
And if you are wondering if
there is a real world example
that proves this stove theory
perfectly, a place where the
water was boiled, the heat was
removed, and the equilibrium
immediately returned, the essay
points us to one specific
country.
The ultimate case study.
A country that has demonstrated
this principle more clearly and
more brutally than almost any
place on Earth.
The graveyard of empires.
Afghanistan.
Afghanistan is the undeniable
case study for this metaphor,
and the author outlines a multi
century pattern here that is
frankly chilling in its exact
repetition.
It's it's almost unbelievable
when you lay it all out.
We're talking about empires
marching into Afghanistan for
centuries, and every single one
of them arriving completely
convinced that they were the
ones who could finally reshape
it.
Let's look at the timeline the
TXT provides.
You have the British Empire
attempting to impose its will in
the 19th century, then you have
the Soviet Union trying it in
the 20th century, and finally
the United States attempting it
in the 21st century 3.
Different century. 3 entirely
different centuries, 3 entirely
different global superpowers at
the absolute height of their
strength, 3 completely different
political ideologies motivating
them.
Right.
And yet, the author notes that
each and every time the exact
same pattern appeared.
So what does that anatomy of an
invasion actually look like?
Well.
According to the essay, it
always starts exactly the same
way the Empire arrives.
They bring vastly superior
technology.
They bring overwhelming,
unimaginable firepower.
And a theory.
Crucially, they bring a very
confident, very rigid theory
about exactly how the country
should be governed.
They show up with their specific
version of the quote UN quote
correct political system.
And how do the locals respond to
this massive influx of power?
The text uses a phrase here that
I think is vital.
It says local factions cooperate
just enough to survive.
Just enough, right?
They aren't suddenly converting
to the Empire's confident theory
of governance.
They aren't having ideological
epiphanies.
They're adapting to the sudden
massive influx of heat on the
stove.
Because with the Empire comes an
absolute flood of resources.
Exactly.
The essay notes that money
floods the country, historical
alliances shift constantly to
accommodate the new reality, and
everyone on the ground figures
out how to extract as much
benefit as possible from the
presence of the foreign power.
It is entirely transactional.
It's survival and it's
opportunism.
The locals understand something
the Empire doesn't.
The Empire is just the flame.
As long as the flame is turned
up, you utilize the heat.
You take the weapons, you take
the funding, you take the
infrastructure.
But the locals also know
something else, something deeply
ingrained in their history.
Empires always eventually grow
tired.
Yes, the inevitable fatigue of
the intervening power.
The author lays out exactly how
this fatigue sets in.
It isn't usually a military
defeat in the traditional sense.
The Empire grows tired because
the public back home loses
patience with a war they don't
really understand right, Or the
financial and military resources
become too strained by other
global commitments.
Or the political leadership
changes back in the Empire's
capital, bringing in a new
administration that campaigned
on ending the war.
Whatever the specific catalyst
is, the result is always exactly
the same.
The hand reaches for the dial
and the flame of the pot is
turned.
Down.
And what happens when that flame
turns down?
The equilibrium reasserts itself
exactly as the metaphor.
The author compares the
immediate aftermath of two
specific historical withdrawals
to make this point.
Look at what happened when the
Soviets finally withdrew in
1989.
Right, a perfect example.
The text notes that almost
immediately, the country
fractured into warlord
territories that were dominated
by various mujahedin factions.
The artificial Soviet order
evaporated the literal moment
the Soviet troops drove back
across the border.
Right.
And then we Fast forward 3
decades, the United States
withdraws.
And he also points out that the
exact same underlying political
structure reemerged almost
overnight.
It was startling how fast it
happened.
It was, but here is the really
sharp critical observation the
author makes.
The labels changed, but the
reality didn't. 3 decades ago we
called those fundamentalist
fighters the Mujahideen.
Today, we call them the Taliban.
The labels changed.
The labels we applied to them in
our newspapers changed, but the
actual underlying political and
social structure of the region
did not shift an inch.
There is a quote from the text
here that is just devastating
quote.
Afghanistan simply waited out
the empire.
It perfectly encapsulates the
entire reality of the boiling
pot.
The water doesn't somehow change
its fundamental nature just
because it's boiling.
No, it doesn't it.
Doesn't become a different
substance, it just waits for the
heat to be removed so it can
return to room temperature.
The local organic structures
simply outlasted the intense
impatience of the foreign
empires.
So if Afghanistan gives us the
absolute clearest, most
undeniable picture of the
failure to build a new state
from the outside, the essay then
pivots to an even darker
reality.
Yeah, this part is heavy.
Because if Afghanistan shows the
failure of building a state, the
recent history of the Middle
East shows the terrible, often
hidden costs of tearing one
down.
The author brings up what they
explicitly call a deeply
uncomfortable revelation about
the removal of authoritarian
regimes over the last two
decades.
And it is deeply uncomfortable
because it forces the listener
to confront of the brutal
tension between morality and
stability.
It really does.
The text examines 3 specific,
very famous case studies to make
this point.
First, it looks at Iraq under
Saddam Hussein.
The author describes Iraq under
Hussein as a centralized state
with rigid borders and
functioning infrastructure
enforced by a security
apparatus.
That was incredibly brutal, yes,
but also highly coherent.
Brutal but coherent is the key
phrase there.
Then the text points to Libya
under Muammar Gaddafi.
Under Gaddafi, despite his
erratic nature and his tyranny,
Libya remained a unified nation
state with functioning national
institutions and a strict
internal order.
And the third example.
The third example provided is
Syria.
Under Bashar al-Assad, Syria
maintains strict internal
stability through deeply
entrenched authoritarian power
right up until the civil war
fractured the entire country.
Now, what ties these three
specific examples together in
the author's framework?
The text points out that
removing these authoritarian
regimes, taking out the brutal
dictators at the very top of the
pyramid, did not automatically
produce thriving Liberal
Democratic societies.
And remember, that was the
entire promise of the
interventionists back in 2005.
That was Sharansky's thesis.
Exactly.
Remove the bad guy, take the
boot off the neck of the people,
and the natural, inherent human
desire for democracy will
immediately flourish.
But the uncomfortable revelation
the author highlights is that
removing these regimes actually
revealed something terrifying.
It revealed how remarkably,
terrifyingly thin the underlying
national cohesion of those
countries actually was.
This is a massive, vital point.
It really is.
The author is arguing that these
regimes, as horrific and
universally condemned as they
were, we're actually the only
things holding together
political systems that were
incredibly fragile.
Right, because these were not
homogeneous societies.
Not at all.
These were societies defined by
deep ancient tribal divisions,
by bitter sectarian rivalries,
and by massive regional
disparities.
The heavy authoritarian fist of
the central government was in
many ways the only force binding
those arbitrary borders
together.
So the question becomes, when an
outside force comes in and
shatters that central authority,
what actually happens?
The vacuum opens.
That is what happens.
You remove the dictator, you
dismantle the security
apparatus, and you create a
massive power vacuum.
And nature of horizontal the
vacuum.
Exactly.
And the harsh reality noted in
the text is that when that
vacuum opens, it is almost never
filled by polite parliamentary
debate.
It is not filled by peaceful
constitutional conventions where
everyone agrees on a new Bill of
Rights.
The vacuum is filled by heavily
armed militias.
It is filled by warlords, by
sectarian violence and by
insurgency.
So what does this all mean?
How did the incredibly smart
policymakers who promised that
removing dictators would
inevitably lead to blooming
democracies get it so
incredibly, disastrously wrong?
It's the $1,000,000 question.
The text suggests it comes down
to a fundamental, profound
misunderstanding of how
political systems are actually
formed in the first place, and
this brings us to the core
foundational philosophy of the
author.
The author states their
philosophy incredibly plainly.
They say their instinct has
always leaned much closer to
sovereignty than to
universalism.
Let's unpack what those two
terms actually mean in the
context of foreign policy,
because they are crucial to
understanding the rest of the
essay so far.
Universalism is the belief that
certain political values and
systems, specifically Western
liberal democracy, are
universally applicable and
inherently desired by all people
everywhere, regardless of their
specific history or culture.
Right.
Universalism assumes that deep
down, everyone is just a
frustrated Democrat waiting to
be liberated.
Exactly.
Sovereignty, on the other hand,
respects the independent, often
messy development of nations.
The author asserts that cultures
are real, distinct entities.
Nations are real.
And crucially, political systems
cannot be mass produced.
They grow organically out of
centuries of specific historical
experience, geographical
realities and unique social
structures.
I have to say I love the analogy
the author uses here because it
feels so perfectly tailored to
how we think today.
The software one.
Yes, it's got a dry joke about
tech support.
The author critiques the idea
that political systems can
simply be installed from the
outside, like software.
It is such a brilliant way to
phrase it.
It really is.
You can't just take a nation
with thousands of years of
specific tribal history, deep
sectarian divides, and totally
different cultural foundations
and just decide to download
Democracy 2 point O into their
capital city and expect the
hardware to successfully run it
right.
It's like trying to install the
latest iOS onto an old Rotary
phone and acting shocked when
you can't use the touch screen.
That software analogy is
absolutely perfect for
illustrating the absurdity of
the interventionist mindset.
It makes it so clear.
The modern doctrine of democracy
promotion, according to the
text, operates entirely on this
flawed assumption.
It assumes that every single
society on Earth is naturally
moving toward the exact same
institutional endpoint, and that
they simply need an enlightened
outside power to help them get
there faster.
And the author views that with
skepticism.
Deep, profound skepticism.
They compare it to a modern form
of ideological colonialism.
Ideological colonialism.
That is a very heavy, very
loaded phrase.
It is meant to be.
The text elaborates on this
concept by comparing the empires
of the past to the superpowers
of the present.
It notes that empires of the
past, say the Spanish or the
British, used to explicitly
export religion and monarchy.
They would conquer a land, build
their churches, install their
proxy kings and demand
allegiance to their God.
Today, the text argues, powerful
modern states export political
institutions.
Instead, we build parliaments
and run elections.
The vocabulary has completely
changed to sound more
benevolent, but the underlying
arrogant assumption is
remarkably similar.
And what exactly is that
assumption?
It's the unshakable belief that
our system is not merely ours,
but the correct destination for
everyone.
That is the ideological
arrogance the author is
highlighting.
It is the belief that your
specific way of organizing a
society is the objective
universal truth, and therefore
you have a moral mandate to
impose it on the rest of the
world, whether they have the
societal hardware to run it or
not.
And this realization leads the
author to a really fascinating
observation about the nature of
American politics itself.
Oh, this shakes up how a lot of
people view the political
landscape.
It does.
The author has come to believe
that the real, defining divide
in US foreign policy is not
actually between the political
left and the political right.
We are so heavily conditioned to
see every single issue through a
strict partisan lens.
Democrats versus Republicans,
liberals versus conservatives.
Always.
But the text argues the true
dividing line is actually
between interventionists on one
side and those advocating for
restraint on the other.
This is where we need to gently
remind you, the listener, of our
impartiality rules.
Yes.
Very important here.
The author provides a very sharp
critique of two major political
factions here, neoconservatives
on the political right and
liberal internationalists on the
political left.
Again, we are impartially
analyzing the author's thesis,
not endorsing their specific
framing exactly, but let's
define these groups as the
author sees them.
Neoconservatives generally argue
for using American military
primacy to actively shape global
events and promote democracy,
often arguing that American
security depends on a democratic
world order.
Right.
And then on the other side.
Liberal internationalists also
believe in active global
engagement, but they often frame
it more around humanitarian
intervention, protecting human
rights and enforcing
international norms.
Right.
So these different language,
they prioritize different
immediate goals.
But the author's thesis is that
while these two groups,
neoconservatives and liberal
internationalists, often appear
to disagree passionately on
cable news about rhetoric, or
about which global alliances to
prioritize, or about the
specific military tactics to
use, they actually share a
fundamental foundational
premise.
Exactly.
The author argues that both the
right wing interventionist and
the left wing interventionist
share the exact same core belief
that the United States has both
the moral responsibility and the
practical ability to
definitively shape political
outcomes across the globe.
It's the same base code.
Yes, in the author's view,
despite all their bitter
partisan bickering, they really
just represent two different
faces of the exact same doctrine
of global intervention.
They both believe they can keep
the pot boiling.
And establishing that premise,
the idea that the establishment
wings of both major political
parties are fundamentally,
inescapably interventionist is
absolutely necessary to
understand the very personal,
highly political confession the
author makes next in the essay.
Yes, the essay takes a very
direct personal turn here.
It does.
And listener, as we noted
earlier, we are entering the
territory of recent presidential
voting records.
We are maintaining strict
impartiality.
We are not judging and
validating or endorsing the
author's vote.
But we absolutely must discuss
it, because it is the linchpin
to understanding the depth of
their frustration with the
events of 2026.
So what is the the confession?
The author openly confesses that
they voted for Donald Trump, and
not just once, but three times
the.
Crucial defining part of this
confession is the specific
reason the author provides for
those votes.
Yes, the reason is everything
here.
The text explicitly states that
the only reason the author voted
for Trump three times was
because he promised something
very simple, very direct.
No new Foreign Wars.
According to the essay, Trump
presented himself as a
nationalist, A populist and most
importantly for the author's
framework, an anti
interventionist.
The author notes that Trump
specifically and loudly
positioned himself against both
of the establishment
interventionist wings we just
define.
He went after both sides.
Right.
He campaigned aggressively
against the neoconservative
foreign policy that had
historically dominated the
Republican Party, mocking the
Iraq war and nation building.
And he also positioned himself
against the liberal
internationalist that had become
common in the Democratic Party.
So for the author it was a
single issue vote.
Completely for the author, and
they describe themselves as a
deeply weary voter who believed
the US had spent two solid
decades wandering blindly into
unnecessary destructive
conflicts.
That specific anti
interventionist promise mattered
above absolutely all else, the
text says.
It was the singular decisive
issue for them.
So what does this all mean?
Understanding that deep seated
desperate desire for restraint
and the significant political
choices the author made in
pursuit of it, It brings us
crashing right back to the
present moment in the essay.
Back to the shockwaves.
It brings us back to the
overswing, crushing
disappointment of watching the
news on February 28th, 2026.
The text says simply quote and
yet here we are again.
Here we are again.
You can practically hear the
exhaustion radiating off the
page in that phrase.
You really can.
After decades of bitter debate,
after all the stark warnings
about boiling pots and the
fragile nature of authoritarian
regimes, after all the political
realignments supposedly meant to
stop the endless wars, the US
and Israel launched massive
strikes on Iran.
The pot is back on the stove.
Exactly.
The author lists the cycle
playing out a new step by
predictable step.
Another enemy identified as an
existential strategic and moral
threat.
Another urgent argument that
military action is the only
necessary option to prevent a
much worse future.
Another confident belief that
removing a dangerous regime's
leadership will miraculously
produce a more stable political
order.
As we discussed earlier, the
author does maintain a sliver of
historical humility.
Which is fair.
They can see that perhaps in
this one specific instance, the
military intervention will
actually change events for the
better.
But they immediately counter
that tiny concession with the
overwhelming, overarching lesson
of the past two decades.
And this might be the most
important take away of the
entire essay.
I think so too.
History shows the destroying the
monster rarely, if ever,
destroys the ecosystem that
produced the monster in the
first place.
That is such a vital, profound
distinction.
It is the difference between
tactics and strategy.
You might successfully target
the leadership compound.
You might launch the perfect
strike and kill the supreme
leader.
You might eliminate the specific
monster you were aiming at.
Right.
But what about the soil that
grew the monster?
What about the historical
grievances, the economic
despair, the religion, religious
zealotry or the sectarian hatred
that created the conditions for
that regime to rise?
If you don't change the
ecosystem, which as we've
established is nearly impossible
to do from the outside, a new
monster just grows in its place.
And the text returns to the
stove metaphor one last time to
drive this point home
permanently, unless the outside
power intends to keep the flame
under the pot burning
indefinitely.
Which means occupying forever.
Exactly.
Unless you are willing to
occupy, fund, and militarily
suppress that ecosystem forever,
the system will eventually,
inevitably cool and revert to
its own historical equilibrium.
Which serves as the perfect
elegant segue back to where this
entire philosophical journey
started.
John Quincy Adams.
Yes, the author revisits that
1821 warning with a much more
nuanced interpretation.
Adams did not argue that
monsters do not exist.
No, not at all.
As the text notes, history
provides plenty of horrific
evidence that monsters
absolutely do exist in the
world.
There are brutal regimes.
There are genocidal dictators
and there are incredibly
dangerous threats to human life.
But Adam's warning wasn't about
denying the existence of evil in
the world.
His warning was about what
fundamentally happens to a
nation when it defines its core
animating mission as destroying
those monsters abroad.
The author points out the fatal,
tragic flaw in that noble
sounding mission.
The supply of monsters never
ever runs out.
Exactly.
It becomes an endlessly self
perpetuating cycle.
The text lays out the brutal
logic of this cycle.
Every single decade produces a
new adversary.
Always.
That new adversary inevitably
becomes framed by politicians
and the media as a moral
imperative, a threat so evil, so
uniquely dangerous that it
simply must be confronted
militarily.
And once the conflict is framed
as a moral imperative,
advocating for restraint
suddenly feels like weakness.
Yes, you are told you're an
isolationist, or worse, that you
are actively appeasing a
monster.
And when restraint becomes
culturally synonymous with
weakness, the crusade becomes
permanent.
The permanent crusade.
I want you to really think about
that phrase.
It means there will never be a
final victory parade.
There will always be another
underground facility to strike,
another regional proxy network
to disrupt, another brutal
regime to topple for the sake of
supposed global safety.
The author laments that America
was to be the champion of
freedom by example, rather than
by crusade by right.
You are supposed to build a
society so free, so prosperous,
and so stable that other nations
want to emulate it organically.
You don't force them at gunpoint
to adopt your institutions.
And yet, as the tech states with
a profound sense of resignation,
once again the United States
finds itself abroad heavily
armed, confronting another enemy
described as a monster that
simply must be destroyed.
The cycle has not broken.
The stove is still on, which
leads the author to ask the
exact same haunting question
they asked 21 years ago in 2005.
Listen closely.
Did this final thought from the
text It's.
Powerful.
If maintaining the system we
want requires permanent
intervention, permanent pressure
and permanent war, then have we
really exported democracy at
all?
Or have we simply placed another
pot on the stove and turn the
flame up again?
It forces you to realize that
what we so optimistically called
building democracy might just be
the meticulous, exhausting,
endlessly violent management of
a rolling boil.
Wow.
We've covered an incredible
amount of complex ground today.
We started with the immediate
chaotic shock waves of the 2026
military strikes in Iran, the
convulsing oil markets, the
uncertainty in the Persian Gulf,
the sudden death of common A We.
Covered a lot.
We trace the author's profound
feeling of recognition back to a
2005 blog post contrasting
Sharansky's belief in exporting
democracy with Buchanan's
warnings about intervention
causing chaos.
We broke down the mechanics of
artificial order using the
incredibly vivid metaphor of a
boiling pot on a stove.
We.
Look closely at the ghosts of
Afghanistan waiting out three
different empires.
We confronted the uncomfortable
truth about the chaotic militia
filled vacuum left behind by
collapsed dictatorships in Iraq,
Libya and Syria.
We examined the profound
philosophical difference between
allowing sovereign development
and forcing ideological
colonialism.
And we've seen how the desperate
desire to escape the cycle of
endless intervention drove
massive political decisions.
Only to end up right back where
we started, locked in what looks
exactly like a permanent
crusade.
It is a sweeping, somewhat
sobering framework to view the
world through.
But before we wrap up, I want to
leave you, the listener, with
one final provocative thought to
Mull over.
Let's hear it.
It builds directly on the
author's analysis, but looks at
the consequences from a slightly
different angle.
The author talked extensively
about how empires eventually
turned down the flame because
they get tired, the public loses
patience, and resources become
dangerously strained.
The inevitable fatigue of empire
that we saw with the British and
the Soviets.
Exactly so.
Consider this realization.
If maintaining this artificial
order abroad requires permanent
intervention, permanent pressure
and permanent war, what does
that permanent crusade do to the
pot of water back home?
Oh wow.
If an empire spends all its
energy, all its money, and all
its political focus acting as
the eternal flame for the rest
of the world, does it risk
burning out its own societal
equilibrium?
That's a great question.
Does the massive, exhausting
effort to artificially export
freedom ultimately degrade the
very freedom, stability and
prosperity the nation was trying
to champion by example in the
first place?
It is a question of whether the
flame, if left burning long
enough, eventually consumes the
stove itself.
That is an incredibly haunting
thought to leave off on.
Can you endlessly export order
abroad without eventually
importing chaos at home?
I want to thank you, the
listener, for joining us on this
really complex, deeply important
deep dive.
It's been a great discussion.
It really has.
The next time you turn on the
news and hear the familiar,
confident arguments that a new
monster is simply must be
destroyed for the sake of peace,
I encourage you to think back to
the boiling pot.
Remember the warnings of 1821
and ask yourself what kind of
equilibrium we are actually
creating.
Welcome to you.
The debate to set the stage for
today's discussion.
The date is shortly after
February 28th, 2026, and the
geopolitical landscape has just
experienced a really seismic
shift. the United States and
Israel have launched A
coordinated military strike
campaign against Iran.
We're looking at opening waves
that targeted military
facilities, command centers, and
leadership compounds.
This actually resulted in the
death of Iran Supreme Leader Ali
Khamenei, alongside several
senior figures in their military
hierarchy, and unsurprisingly,
the region has immediately
ignited.
Right.
And we're seeing the blowback
happen in real time.
Iran is retaliating with
missiles and drones aimed at US
bases and Israeli targets.
Global oil markets are
convulsing.
Shipping through the Persian
Gulf is suddenly fraught with
just severe uncertainty.
And governments worldwide are
really scrambling to figure out
what the next phase of this
escalation looks like.
Which brings us to the core
disagreement emerging from our
source material today.
The central question is, does
removing a dangerous
authoritarian regime actually
create the necessary conditions
for a safer Middle East and a
more stable global order?
And looking at the text, my
stance representing the
interventionist perspective, is
that confronting immediate
existential threats with
military force is often the
necessary least bad option to
prevent far greater regional
instability.
Authoritarian regimes are
inherently unstable and, well,
sometimes you just have to act.
And I take a much more skeptical
view of that kind of
intervention because human
cultures and nations aren't
smartphones.
You can't just install a new
political system from the
outside like a software update.
My perspective representing
restraint is that aggressive
interventionism fundamentally
misreads how human societies
operate.
Tragically, it usually creates
the exact instability it claims
to be solving.
Let's start with a foundational
idea from the early 2000s that
the source material highlights.
You're familiar with the
philosophy popularized by
figures like Natan Taransky.
The Soviet dissident?
Yeah, he famously argued about
the difference between fierce
societies and free societies.
Exactly.
The core thesis there is that if
people cannot walk into a town
square and criticize their
government without fear of
arrest, that society is
inherently unstable.
IT projects this massive
illusion of strength, but it's
really a hollow structure
maintained entirely by coercion.
There is no actual consent of
the governed.
From that viewpoint, dismantling
structures of terror ultimately
makes the world safer.
But applying a Cold War
dissidents framework to the
modern Middle East is a massive
leap.
Is it, though?
Look at Washington and
Jerusalem's justifications for
these 2026 strikes.
We're talking about Iran's
nuclear ambitions, its advanced
missile programs, and its vast
regional proxy networks
financing terror from Lebanon to
Yemen.
These aren't theoretical
concerns.
They constitute A genuine,
actionable, and empirical threat
to global security.
Intervention is undeniably
messy.
It carries profound risks, but
history occasionally produces
situations where force truly is
the least bad option.
Removing a highly dangerous
regime that operates as a Nexus
of international terrorism is a
necessary step to deal with a
system that was already a
profound threat.
I completely disagree with that
premise, and I draw heavily on
historical warnings that have
echoed through American history
to explain why the foundation of
the restraint perspective is
perfectly captured by John
Quincy Adams 1821 warning.
He said America should not go
abroad in search of monsters to
destroy.
We can wish freedom for all
nations, we can encourage it by
our example, But we should be
the vindicator only of our own.
You really think Adam's
framework from the 1800s applies
to a regime actively pursuing
nuclear weapons in 2026?
I think human nature hasn't
changed since the 1800s.
As Pat Buchanan and other
critics of interventionism have
long argued, the act of
intervention itself routinely
creates the chaos it attempts to
cure.
Political systems grow
organically out of historical
experience, social structure,
and cultural realities.
The modern doctrine of
intervention, this assumption
that every society is naturally
moving toward Western democracy
and just needs a few air strikes
to get there faster, is
essentially a form of
ideological colonialism.
Ideological colonialism is a
heavy charge.
But it's accurate.
Empires used to export religion
in monarchy.
Today powerful states try to
export political institutions.
It fundamentally misreads how
cultures operate.
To really ground this, let me
give you a metaphor from the
text that perfectly captures why
external political order is an
illusion.
Imagine a pot of water sitting
on an aluminum stove.
You turn on the flame, and the
water begins to boil.
Turn the feet down, the boil in
slows.
Turn the flame off entirely, and
the water cools quickly.
External political order works
exactly like that, and outside
power acts as the flame.
It supplies the troops, the
money, the weapons, the economic
sanctions and the diplomatic
pressure.
As long as that intense heat is
applied, a certain kind of
artificial order is maintained.
So you're talking about the
artificial stability of an
occupation?
Right, but the absolute second
the public at home loses
patience and that heat is
reduced, the society inevitably
reverts to its own equilibrium.
The boiling stops, and the
underlying social structure
reasserts itself.
Policy makers repeatedly assume
that they can just leave the
water boiling permanently, but
history keeps proving that this
kind of external order is an
illusion.
I understand the pot on the
stove mechanics, but that
metaphor has a fatal flaw.
It assumes our only goal in 2026
is to perpetually boil the water
to engage in endless utopian
nation building in Iran that
completely mischaracterizes the
strategic reality.
How so?
The strikes killed the Supreme
leader.
You don't decapitate a state
without taking responsibility
for the ensuing chaos.
These strikes were not about
building a new Iranian nation
from scratch.
They were about destroying an
active ecosystem of nuclear and
proxy threats.
Let's lean on a crucial
concession from the text itself.
History sometimes produces
situations where intervention
genuinely changes events for the
better.
We don't have to keep the pot
boiling forever if our primary
objective is simply to take a
highly dangerous element out of
the pot, or, frankly, to break a
stove that threatens to burn
down the entire neighborhood.
Break the stove, then what?
You just walk away.
You auditor the immediate
trajectory of a genuine threat.
The disruption of a regime's
capacity to build nuclear
weapons doesn't require
permanent occupation, It
requires decisive action.
You're assuming we can just
surgically remove the bad parts
and leave the rest intact.
Let me look at the actual data
and the clearest historical
example we have, which is
Afghanistan.
The source material points out
that empires have marched into
Afghanistan for centuries,
convinced they could reshape it
or at least neutralize it.
Afghanistan is a completely
different strategic landscape
than Iran.
The mechanics of foreign
intervention are exactly the
same.
The British tried in the 19th
century, the Soviets tried with
mechanized infantry in the 20th,
the United States tried with
drones and nation building in
the 21st, and the exact same
pattern appears every single
time the Empire arrives, with
superior technology,
overwhelming firepower, and a
highly confident theory of how
the country should be managed.
And you're saying the local
populations just wait them out?
They do more than wait.
Local factions adapt just enough
to extract the benefits.
They cooperate just enough to
survive.
Money floods the country,
alliances shift constantly, and
everyone milks the foreign power
for resources.
Eventually, the empire tires.
The public at home loses
patience.
The flame under the pot is
turned down.
When the Soviets withdrew the
Mujahideen, the Islamic
guerrilla fighters who battled
them took over.
When the US withdrew, the
Taliban took over.
The labels changed, but the
underlying structure simply
waited out the empire.
You cannot easily decouple A
surgical strike from the massive
gravity well of regional
complexities that follow.
I completely agree that
Afghanistan showcases the
profound limits of nation
building.
The hubris of attempting to
permanently rewire a society's
internal political structure is
real, but the failure to create
a Jeffersonian democracy in
Kabul does not invalidate the
strategic necessity of stopping
acute international threats.
But at what cost?
We just keep repeating the
cycle.
Look at the consensus, the text
points out.
Neoconservatives on the right,
the folks who want to export
democracy, and liberal
internationalists on the left,
the folks who want to enforce
global human rights norms.
They share a deeper consensus.
They both agree that the United
States has the responsibility
and the ability to shape global
outcomes.
Yes, the establishment
consensus, and that consensus
has a terrible track record.
It exists for a reason, though.
It exists because ignoring these
monsters is a luxury that the
United States and the global
order it anchors simply cannot
afford.
If a regime is actively pursuing
nuclear weapons and
orchestrating a network of
regional terrorism, stepping
back and allowing that organic
equilibrium to form means
accepting an equilibrium where
dirty bombs or ballistic
missiles dictate global
security.
We can acknowledge the
structural resilience of local
factions without abdicating our
responsibility to neutralize
threats that extend far beyond
their borders.
But you're ignoring the
alternative.
What happens when you neutralize
the threat?
Let's bring up the deeply
uncomfortable truths of Iraq,
Libya and Syria, discussing the
material.
Saddam Hussein, Muammar Gaddafi
and Bashar al-Assad were brutal,
ruthless dictators.
Nobody disputes that.
Right.
They maintained powers strictly
through terror and secret
police.
Yet under their rule, those
nations functioned as
centralized states.
They maintained rigid borders,
functioning infrastructure, and
internal order through their
security apparatuses.
The Western assumption was that
removing these dictators would
allow the suppressed Liberal
Democratic desires of the
populist to flourish.
Instead, removing them exposed
how astonishingly thin the
underlying national cohesion
actually was.
Because the cohesion was
artificial, it was forced.
But it was functional.
Take a wreck.
Saddam's Baathist Party was
deeply oppressive.
But when the central authority
collapsed in a society
fundamentally defined by tribal
and sectarian divisions, Sunni,
Shia, Kurd, the vacuum wasn't
filled by parliamentary debate,
it was filled by heavily armed
militias.
The intervention didn't create
the divisions, it just removed
the lid from a pressure cooker
that was already boiling.
The intervention didn't stop a
monster.
It fractured the society and
birthed a dozen new
uncontrollable monsters.
Exactly, which proves my point.
The insight here is that
dictatorship isn't stability,
it's just a delayed explosion.
You're relying on a mirage of
stability.
A delayed explosion is still an
explosion, and the human toll of
the ensuing civil conflicts in
those countries was devastating.
I fully acknowledge the tragic
outcomes in Iraq, Libya and
Syria, but let's apply the
source materials framing of
authoritarian fragility to those
exact examples.
If Saddam Hussein or Muammar
Gaddafi were holding together
systems that were already that
incredibly fragile, systems
devoid of any organic national
cohesion, then maintaining them
in power was an illusion of true
security.
A system that fractures the
moment the dictator falls was
never stable to begin with.
But replacing an illusion of
security with the reality of a
bloody civil war is not an
improvement for the people
living there or for the region.
Leaving a dangerous regime in
power simply because we fear the
vacuum ignores what that regime
is doing while in power.
In the case of Iran in 2026, you
have a regime explicitly
dedicated to exporting terrorism
and destabilizing its neighbors.
Leaving them untouched
guarantees instability anyway.
When forced to choose between
confronting A fragile, hostile
regime now or allowing it to
achieve nuclear deterrence while
spreading chaos, intervention
remains the least bad option.
Which your least bad option
calculation completely ignores
the domestic cost.
You're looking entirely at the
geopolitics and ignoring the
political breaking point of the
society actually executing the
intervention.
You mean the American voters?
Yes, and the text introduces A
striking personal anecdotes that
we absolutely have to dive into.
The author confesses to voting
for Donald Trump three times,
strictly and exclusively because
Trump promised something very
simple.
No new foreign wars.
It's a powerful anecdote because
it highlights a massive
disconnect between the foreign
policy establishment and the
general electorate.
Exactly, he presented himself as
an anti interventionist,
positioning himself against both
that neoconservative right and
the liberal interventionist left
consensus you mentioned earlier.
Think about what it means for a
middle class taxpayer in Ohio.
They're asked to fund multi
trillion dollar campaigns in the
Middle East while bridges at
home are crumbling.
For voters who felt the United
States had spent two decades
wandering into unnecessary,
bloody and expensive conflicts,
that promise of no new wars was
the decisive issue.
I don't dismiss that fatigue at
all.
It's empirically measurable and
entirely rational after the last
20 years.
Then you have to look at the
consequences of ignoring it.
When the foreign policy
establishment frames every new
adversary as a moral imperative
and every dictator as a monster
that must be destroyed, they
make restraint feel like a moral
weakness.
But Adam's warned us about this.
Once you define your mission as
destroying monsters abroad, the
supply of monsters never runs
out.
The crusade becomes permanent,
and a permanent crusade
eventually hollows out the
Republic from the inside,
exhausting the very voters who
were asked to fund and fight
these endless campaigns.
The domestic frustration is
real.
But isolationism, even when
driven by understandable
domestic exhaustion, simply
cannot hold when the supply of
real factual threats forces a
response.
The 2026 strikes on Iran weren't
driven by desire for a permanent
crusade.
They were driven by a regime
actively hostile to global
stability.
But framing every regional power
play as a threat to global
stability is exactly how the
Crusade becomes permanent.
We can acknowledge the deep,
legitimate desire for no new
foreign wars, but we must also
reiterate that being a champion
of freedom by example does not
immunize a nation from having to
deal with hostile state actors
operating aggressively on the
global stage.
If you declare that you will
never intervene, you signal to
authoritarian regimes that they
have a free hand.
They can expand their influence,
develop weapons of mass
destruction, and terrorize their
neighbors without consequence.
So the United States has to be
the global policeman forever,
regardless of the domestic toll.
The US and its allies do not
have the luxury of retreating
behind two oceans while the
global order, which underwrites
our own security and economic
prosperity, is dismantled by
adversaries.
You can't separate domestic
prosperity from global
stability.
But does our intervention
actually secure that global
order, or does it merely
perpetuate a cycle of chaos?
We keep identifying strategic
and moral threats.
We keep arguing that military
action is necessary to prevent a
worse future.
And we keep believing that
removing a regime will produce
stability, but history shows
that destroying the monster
rarely destroys the ecosystem
that produced the monster in the
first place.
That's a fair challenge.
You killed Khamenei in these
2026 strikes, but did you kill
the underlying historical
grievances, the religious
fervor, or the regional dynamics
that empowered him?
No, unless Washington and
Jerusalem intend to keep the
flame under the Iranian pot
burning indefinitely, that
system will eventually cool and
revert to whatever equilibrium
the Iranian society itself
produces.
The structural realities always
outlast the foreign bombs.
Looking at this debate
comprehensively, I can see that
the history of regime change is
fraught with deep complexities,
unintended consequences, and
immense tragedy.
You've made a strong case for
the structural resilience of
these societies.
However, authoritarian regimes
that aggressively seek weapons
of mass destruction and export
terror are inherently unstable.
They pose an unacceptable risk
to global security.
Confronting these destabilizing
forces, as seen in the 2026
strikes against Iran, is not an
exercise in utopia nation
building.
It is a tragic but necessary
burden to prevent far worse
geopolitical futures.
Sometimes you have to break the
machinery of a threat, even if
you cannot control the exact
shape of the pieces that remain.
And from the perspective of
restraint, the counter argument
remains clear.
True enduring stability cannot
be enforced by external pressure
or military strikes.
Political systems and social
orders must grow out of their
own historical experience.
Continuously seeking out
monsters abroad to destroy
merely replaces organic societal
development with permanent war,
hollowing out our own Republic
and exhausting our citizenry in
the process.
We have to recognize the limits
of our power and abandoned the
ideological colonialism that
assumes we can bomb a society
into a better equilibrium.
I think where we fundamentally
converge in this discussion is
on the profound difficulty of
balancing domestic patients with
global security.
The fatigue of the electric that
you highlighted is undeniable,
yet the threats on the global
stage are equally real and
pressing.
Exactly As we look at the
fallout from these 2026 strikes
on Iran, we can both agree that
the ultimate outcomes will
likely hinge on whether the US
and Israel we actually have a
realistic, clear eyed plan for
the equilibrium that follows the
destruction of the regime's
leadership.
Right, and that brings us back
to the enduring relevance of
John Quincy Adams warning from
over 2 centuries ago.
As the dust settles in Tehran
and the global markets react, it
leaves us all to ponder whether
America is genuinely creating a
safer world through these
actions or for simply placing
yet another pot on the stove,
turning up the flame, and hoping
this time the water boils
differently.
There's certainly much more to
explore on how these events will
unfold and how the underlying
structures of the region will
adapt.
Thank you for joining.
US fictional 2026 military
strike against Iran, which uses
John Quincy Adams warnings and a
boiling pot metaphor to argue
against America's continuous
cycle of foreign
interventionism.
Let's dive straight into the
feedback.
Yeah, let's get right to it.
The abrupt transition from the
deeply personal confession about
voting for Donald Trump to the
broader conclusion leaves a
significant narrative and
logical gap regarding the 2026
strikes.
Right, so the weakness here is
that the text reveals the author
voted for Trump three times.
Specifically because of his anti
interventionist stance.
Exactly.
But it follows this almost
immediately with the phrase.
And yet here we are again,
referring to the massive. 2026
strike on Iran.
The one that killed Supreme
Leader Ali Khamenei?
Yeah.
The essay strongly implies that
the politician elected to stop a
new foreign wars is actually the
one who initiated this new
conflict.
But it completely skips over how
or why this happened.
It really does, by abruptly
jumping from that that very
personal voting confession to
the general conclusion that
history occasionally produces
situations where intervention
changes events.
It leaves the reader hanging.
Completely hanging on a massive
political irony without
unpacking the mechanics of that
ideological betrayal.
I mean, playing devil's advocate
for a second, could the author
just argue that they don't want
to get bogged down in the weeds
of domestic political maneuvers?
I mean they could try.
Maybe they just want to get to
the philosophical point.
Sure, but when you introduce a
highly personal, provocative
element like your own voting
record, you're making a
narrative promise to the reader.
You've introduced a protagonist.
Right, the anti war voter and an
antagonist which is the
inescapable pull of the American
war machine.
But you've skipped the climax of
the story.
You skipped the part where the
antagonist overpowers the chosen
champion.
Exactly.
Without that connective tissue,
the argument feels slightly
truncated right at its most
compelling character driven
moment.
That makes total sense.
We need to fill that gap.
So what is the clear suggestion
to fix this missing link?
The suggestion is to bridge the
gap between the Trump voting
confession and the 2026 Iran
strike by briefly exploring how
this specific anti
interventionist promise
collapsed into neoconservative
action.
We need to show the reader the
mechanics of this
transformation.
Yes, connecting the personal
disappointment to the
geopolitical reality of those
strikes.
Let's see how we can strengthen
this with some practical steps.
What are some concrete examples
for improvement?
Well, keeping in mind that these
are just a few out of all
possible ways of solving the
problem, the first approach
could be to add a dedicated
paragraph analyzing the systemic
pressures of the presidency.
You mean looking at the
institutional forces, the things
that happen behind closed doors?
Right, like the intelligence
apparatus or the military
industrial complex.
Or even international alliances
forcing leaders into
interventionism regardless of
campaign promises.
Precisely, it elevates the essay
from a complaint about a single
politician into a profound
observation about the American
state.
I like that.
What's another route they could
take?
Another concrete example would
be to describe a specific
hypothetical shift in the
administration's rhetoric.
Oh, illustrating how they
pivoted from no new wars to
justifying the assassination of
Iran's military hierarchy.
Exactly showing that rhetorical
evolution grounds the essay in a
gritty, believable political
realism.
You can almost hear the shift
happening in the press
briefings.
Yeah.
And a third example would be
explicitly stating how the two
faces of the same doctrine
ultimately absorbed or
outmaneuvered the populist
resistance.
And by two faces, you mean the
neoconservative and liberal
internationalist BLOB that the
author mentioned earlier.
Right, connecting that
theoretical concept of the BLOB
directly to the failure of the
26 administration creates a.
Really tight narrative
structure.
It rewards the reader for paying
attention.
Moving on to the next area of
focus, the argument that
removing authoritarian regimes
inherently causes instability
overlooks the complex realities
of non intervention and internal
collapse.
This is a crucial point
regarding the section on Iraq,
Libya and Syria.
Because the weakness is that the
text points to those countries
as examples where removing a
strongman revealed fragile
national cohesion.
And created vacuums built by
militias, Yes.
But using Syria as an example of
intervention causing collapse
slightly undermines the
argument.
Because the Syrian civil war
actually fractured the country
while Assad was actively trying
to maintain authoritarian power.
Exactly.
Not merely as a result of his
removal by a foreign empire.
In fact, Assad was never
removed.
Furthermore, while the peace
acknowledges that history
occasionally produces situations
where force is the least bad
option, it never wrestles with
the strongest counter argument.
Which is the devastating
consequences and moral hazards
of strict non intervention when
fragile states collapse
internally.
Right, I see your point about
Syria organically collapsing,
but isn't the author just using
it as shorthand for the region's
overall fragility?
It's a fair question, but when
you write for a highly
knowledgeable audience,
historical precision is your
currency.
If you state that removing Assad
caused the collapse of Syria, a
knowledgeable reader will
immediately pause.
They'll say, wait, he wasn't
removed and the collapse started
from internal protests, and the
moment the reader catches a
historical inaccuracy they start
to doubt the broader
philosophical point.
Neatly categorizing all
instability as a product of
Western intervention
oversimplifies the chaotic
nature of authoritarian regimes.
They often implode organically
due to their own internal
contradictions.
Leaving that unaddressed leaves
the whole piece vulnerable.
So what is the core suggestion
to bulletproof this section?
The suggestion is to strengthen
the essays robust logic by
proactively acknowledging and
dismantling the counter
arguments regarding the human
cost of restraint and clarifying
the historical timeline.
Let's unpack some concrete
examples of how to do that.
How do we handle the Syria issue
first?
Just as one possible way to
approach this, the easiest fix
is to simply clarify the Syria
example by noting that it was
Assad's brutal retention of
power that triggered the massive
fracturing.
And the organic failure of
internal cohesion rather than
Western regime chain right.
Acknowledging this actually
demonstrates that the author
fully grasps the complexity of
the region.
What about the broader issue of
non intervention and its
consequences?
A great concrete example there
is to briefly contrast the chaos
of intervention like the US and
Iraq with the organic chaos of
stripped non intervention.
Acknowledging that leaving the
pot alone sometimes results in
its own localized explosions.
Yes.
By conceding that restraint has
a human cost, the author gains
immense credibility.
Then they can pivot back to
their main thesis.
Arguing that restraint remains
the superior long term strategic
choice.
Exactly what about the
ideological debate going on in
the background the text mentions
not on Sharansky and Pat
Buchanan.
The author should address the
Natan Sharansky argument head
on.
Sharansky argued authoritarian
regimes are inherently unstable
because they lack internal
freedom.
Like taking time bombs.
Right.
The author should concede
Sharansky's point that they are
unstable, but then argue that
exporting democracy via the
military actually accelerates
and weaponizes that instability.
Rather than curing it, that's a
great way to flip the strongest
counterargument.
Let's tackle the final main
point.
The powerful mechanical metaphor
introduced in the middle of the
essay clashes slightly with the
biological metaphor used in the
conclusion.
Yeah, the vivid descriptive
language here is brilliant, but
the conclusion gets a bit
tangled.
The weakness is a mixing of
metaphorical language that
slightly diffuses the thematic
punch of the ending.
The author introduces this
extended metaphor, comparing
foreign intervention to a flame
under an aluminum pot of water.
Turn on the flame.
The water boils.
Turn it off.
The water naturally cools to its
own equilibrium.
It perfectly illustrates the
temporary nature of foreign
imposed order, but in the
conclusion, the text pivots to
stating that destroying the
monster rarely destroys the
ecosystem that produced the
monster.
Moving from the mechanical
imagery of stoves and boiling
water to the biological imagery
of monsters and ecosystems.
Which creates A slight
disjointedness in the imagery
right at the emotional climax of
the peace.
But isn't a monster a
universally understood metaphor
for the blowback of war?
Referencing John Quincy Adams
going abroad in search of
monsters to destroy sounds
great.
Oh, it sounds fantastic, but
think about the cognitive
journey you've just taken the
reader on.
You've spent a significant
portion of the essay training
the reader to visualize the
mechanics of a stove.
Internalizing the logic of heat
and thermodynamics.
To suddenly ask them to abandon
that visual framework and
conjure up a biological
ecosystem breeding mythical
monsters creates cognitive
whiplash.
The competing vocabularies are
fighting each other for the
reader's attention.
Right when you want maximum
resonance.
So what is our suggestion for
harmonizing this?
The suggestion question is to
unify the metaphorical language
in the conclusion so that it
ties seamlessly back to the
earlier imagery of the boiling
pot, creating a tighter, more
resonant ending.
Bringing the monster into the
kitchen, basically.
Let's get into some concrete
examples for this.
Sure, and again, these are just
a few ways to resolve the clash.
One approach is to reframe the
ecosystem concept using the
stove metaphor.
Noting that keeping the flame
high doesn't change the
fundamental nature of the water
in the pot.
Exactly.
It only creates an artificial,
temporary state of boiling that
masks the underlying reality.
So the monster isn't the product
of an ecosystem.
Right.
What if they really want to lean
into the John Quincy Adams quote
though?
They could weave the monster
imagery directly into the fire
metaphor.
Yes.
Another concrete example would
be suggesting that the monsters
are actually born in the very
fires of intervention America
insists on keeping lit.
That flips the narrative
beautifully.
The heat creates the
adversaries.
It really does.
And a third example, if they
absolutely want to keep the word
ecosystem, is to explicitly link
the two concepts.
Clarifying that the ecosystem
breeding the monsters is the
natural equilibrium the water
always reverts to once the
Empire's flame is removed.
Yes, weaving the vocabulary of
heat and equilibrium together
with Adam's monsters makes the
conclusion stop feeling
disjointed.
It hits with the force of an
absolute, absolute, undeniable
truth.
To recap, this critique
highlighted 3 main areas to
elevate the source material.
First bridging the narrative gap
between the author's anti
interventionist voting record
and the 2026 strikes by
exploring how that promise
collapsed. 2nd bulletproofing
the argument by clarifying the
Syria example and addressing the
counter arguments of non
intervention.
And 3rd, harmonizing the boiling
pot and ecosystem.
Metaphors for a stronger
concluding punch.
Implementing these actionable
suggestions will make an already
robust piece even more
compelling.
Please submit your revised work
or future materials back to us
for another critique.